love it love it love it all right ready
for his challenge here we go
this is gonna be super hype we love eric
here let's shout out chess bro you guys
all know who he is
winner gets ten thousand bits is it
first to ten or best of ten
um orpheus it's first to ten right first
to ten here we go i'm gonna focus
there's a lot on the line you guys
[Music]
love stuff in my all right here we go
we're in
first to ten here we go
okay we're gonna play a casio defense
here
i don't wanna i wanna take eric off the
beaten path if anything happens you guys
i'll be checking my stream but
okay knight g6 should be seven
i guess king h8 makes some sense here
okay it takes i'm going to take this as
equal
equal position out of the opening happy
with
yeah let's stick with the night to have
some fun taking with a pawn is basically
just very drawish
but we want we want hardcore tactics
here with eric
i don't know why we're both playing like
it's a bullet game very it's very dry
i don't know if droscot is a draws count
because this is already heading toward
one
okay i need to watch rook f3 ideas
this is a nice position for me
it's got the f5 it could be
tough for me okay i guess i'm gonna take
it
anybody once
let's go h6 i don't want background
problems
i saw this move so i have this
f1
d5 queen e6 is a little annoying
yeah we didn't rock against queen or
shouldn't have allowed that it's kind of
kind of conspicuous here
again it is it is hard to say
let's take obviously now it's fine try
to be solid ideally i'd like some sort
of like
salt just to stop king g1 and then i
want to go a5 maybe the road can go to
a8
yeah it's kind of a draw
i want to go a4 maybe play for a win
here a little bit
he wants rookie seven
so rook f7 i guess makes sense
stopping everything rookie six he is but
then maybe king g8
let's go kimchi in anyway
okay
just to draw i think
rookie seven maybe you can trade queens
there if you want to but i'm not
too concerned about that end game
he's thinking about it he's definitely
evaluating queen c4
no it doesn't doesn't bite
the king of fate
let's go queen g5 swing the queen around
king g3 i don't know what he's okay
queen a7
uh
you can take here sacked the pawn thank
you chest dojo for the raid appreciate
it man
yeah this is annoying
i could have taken what am i doing
cried i got to go here
yeah it's losing on time okay got him
that was close and
close game there flagged him in the end
very close end game
now it's called an expensive mouse all
right good game eric
that was close back and forth there
until the end i mean i somehow tricked
him in that pawn end game got the
opposition
but it was of course a dead draw until
the end we're not going to pretend uh
not going to pretend that i
that i really played well there i played
quite poorly i think
okay now knight a4 it's all theory takes
check and castles yeah i've had this a
million times
g5 94. now i'm gonna say go bishop f4 i
think white is slightly better here
maybe not no what am i doing allowing
rook rt2 like this
stupid this is very bad play by me
i need to think think think i need to
save this this is not a game i want to
lose
okay so queen f5 obviously cannot trade
and i blended a piece here
he doesn't take it
definitely a piece blender now i should
play something a little bit more
mainstream
this is a good lesson learned
very bad game very very bad game i'm
just i just got
in trouble out of the opening and didn't
stop to think about what i was doing
yeah this is not gonna be going to go my
way unfortunately
okay but now we're d1 maybe i can
somehow hold on you guys know how i can
save some positions
okay but now i thought i can maybe take
it
or not no this was losing god damn it
that was so bad
that was such a bad game trying to go h6
here i'm not entirely hopeless yet
h6 there are some chances to draw maybe
okay so h6 he wants rook fade i go rook
h5
okay and if i try to walk in with my
king the rascal goes there
okay okay let's go c4 then c4 b5
okay now h6 is interesting h6 g5 h7 rook
8 shade
okay g6 we can also throw out whatever
let's go for it
oh he wants king g5 yeah i should have
gone b5 but then f4 king h2
this is interesting this is not clear
at all b5 there was also interesting
hey flyerton
nervous but i've created a lot of
chances and he's got very little time
he's got now under a minute basically
okay takes it so now b5 is the key
five is the key
because if i took him oh kng5 he had f4
yeah
yeah so this is all correct
now i thought i'd take it and take it
this is all forced i mean i'm playing
fast but the reality is i have no other
choice
and now i should be able to draw i think
or
i've got a minute on him so
okay but now i check him
simply take okay now i'm i'm pressing
for a win
so b6
b7 but then i go king h4 should be
winning for me already
should be winning for me
yeah it's just winning i mean he has got
no chance of searching g5 coming in g3
unbelievable okay now i just need to um
think about this oops i hit my mic sorry
guys
okay or not let's not think about it
just move
it's just an it's this is a famous
position
zugsvan very famous position and it's
over
one two zero good
very bad games but good result okay
let's repeat the same opening if it
ain't broke don't fix it
okay then h let's try this plan of h6
bishop g5
i've seen it before
i've seen this plan before i don't know
how it's played though maybe i should
just take
castle and then go knight f4 when the
time is right
i mean the trade of the dark squared
bishops should be in my favor
because he's lost with this light
squared bishop that's a little lame
i guess it can go to b3 now this is
slightly better for white
but what else is new picking eight shade
maybe
just to uh prepare some f5 ideas which
should be three
very sensible eric
yeah i guess now knight c7 makes a lot
of sense
again i have to hold a slightly inferior
oh that's a very unpleasant move
yeah i missed this it's a very very very
strong classy move by eric
okay now i have to go knight back to c6
that was a bad idea my move
and again i'm worse again i'm worse
but this one i think i can save maybe
with accurate play
so the question is which one do i take
with if i go d e he's gonna go queen no
i have to take with a knight it's a
no-brainer
yeah i need to switch the openings up
this is not working
this is certainly not working
i'm paralyzed
let's see maybe go bishop g4 okay
definitely probably want to trade one
pair but
okay there he goes queen g4
let's try bishop b6
this move i don't trust
now i can go rookie eight maybe g4
immediately
to play super precisely here one misstep
and the game is over
and i just think i just committed it e5
allowing e5 like an idiot doesn't play
it misses the chance
now i can take at my leisure
yeah that makes sense he's bringing his
king into the game
let's try to rip things open a little
bit an e5 might be winning
let's see what am i doing why am i
opening this up for him i don't know
95 oh i had 95 maybe no i i do have 95
as an idea
okay i feel like there are some tactics
here there's got to be some
some salvation how though
i gotta move you know let's sack this
rook c8 i think this gives me some
chances i think
eric playing very well this game gonna
defuse him if i can win this one that'll
be huge
okay time situation equalized now we've
surpassed him on the clock
which is very important okay now
definitely knight f8 gotta
gotta involve the knight otherwise i'm
never gonna pull this one out
okay now he attacks this uh he's just
not stopping here
i guess 96 on rook c3
makes some sense or rook c2 maybe
yeah this is kind of forced forced
is the russian same no this is some
chances already
i've definitely defended extremely well
but it's a question of is it enough
knight f4 king f4 so close
g6 he's got like e5 ideas so if i go g6
what if i what exactly does he have here
oh this one i missed
what is the idea though is this really
that good
why am i
being had oh my god and i wonder though
that was shitty
some stalemate ideas here
we have five ones
but it's not so easy after queen i5
this is not that easy i mean it is
winning but oh and i allowed this
yeah that was a incredibly played game i
don't know what to say
i came back at some point and then i
just watched it
i need to change my opening i'm like
giving him a huge advantage in the
opening every game
i need to do something sit silly i don't
know if i can get away with you maybe
i'm giving him some light squares on
default
now that was a good game i defended well
i mean it's gonna
lose a couple here we can try this try
to be a little annoying
now i want d4 blast him
blast him with d4
why did i lose that game should not have
lost that game
nikon d4 is an idea and he's got no good
way to defend against it
okay
so f4 is he's playing against f4 clearly
okay let's go king h2
yeah i'm not playing fantastic just but
i'm
just gonna keep a decent level and i
think i can beat him
yeah this is what i was exactly what i
was afraid of
crap letting him off the hook
thanks for the vets cappy
need to get my [ __ ] together here
i could go d5 and c4 i'm not a big fan
of these structures though
i don't really see an alternative
and then maybe f4
no bullets tomorrow now
whoa thank you defender for the sub
appreciate it man
defender of time oh and i have leonard
bishop i mean this is ridiculous
blundering bishop d3 like this kidding
me
still a game though i have some
compensation h4
no this is serious compensation let's
call it a sacrifice
still ridiculous though okay now he
wants knight f6 and harry can be so
annoying when he's good
eric always plays himself down but he's
an incredible player
that's why everybody thinks like i'm so
much stronger he always talks [ __ ] about
himself but he's incredibly strong and i
respect this guy a ton
okay we're going to try to hold this
position
yeah i'm just getting crushed here i
just these blunders are ridiculous
i mean i'm blundering the exchange like
this
maybe b4 and c5 just throw my chips into
the center of the table hope he doesn't
figure things out with 50 seconds
yeah but people always think i'm gonna
crush everybody easily i do crush
everybody but i'm human sometimes i play
badly i mean
just just happens sometimes i mean i'm
not like a machine
okay but this is this is very complex
actually i have a huge i have huge
compensation i one would think
okay five of six now
okay caro is yeah well that's true
some people can't take defeat
foreign
okay this is winning i think
it's got to be completely winning that
was a great stretch see i give myself
credit when i deserve
credit because that stretch okay so boom
boom
boom wait let's not celebrate yet
let's not celebrate just yet
okay we can celebr i'm gonna win
obviously but
yeah okay good big win big win
that was a tough spot okay so let's play
um let's play a rouser let's test him in
the rouser
okay good he plays c3 i know this line
pretty well i think
okay blenders are fun
okay this is a big chance to jump out
with a huge lead here
i can win another one
this is like a hedgehog a pawn up that's
a bit of a yikes
you drive a toyota please define flex
so yeah that's a good car of course i
belong
i could have just taken on c4 that's
probably the practical choice
and played with b4 wake the [ __ ] up
wake the [ __ ] up daniel
h6 there i mean i'm just playing like a
sack of garbage right now
i managed to get from a pawn up crushing
position out of the opening too
i'm not going to say i'm lost here this
is salvageable but it's not good
if i had a penny every time people ask
me for my sleep schedule i'd be like a
multi-billionaire
why do people care i stream when i
stream
garbage total garbage play right now but
but let's put things in perspective i'm
up 3-1 we're good
i'm i i can still win this game i think
and then i'll be up 4-1
and that'll be good we got to get this
game though when i blunt it again
i mean i'm blundering tactics that i
normally don't blunder if he took he had
queen g4
okay but now i win the pawn back so
let's again
maybe i can bring the rook in
if i won the last game i can win this
one the problem is it's more in eric's
style queen g4 i don't know what he's
thinking about queen g4 is crushing
that maybe rookie six i don't know
okay a3 is definitely wrong gives me
life
let's tr let's try to use it rookie
there's bishop c4
i have a chance here to somehow come
back but how do i
disentangle my pieces it's giving me a
tempo
okay let's go ricky six anyway c4 i want
rook g6
yeah he's preparing bishop c4 you can
see what he wants
very good move actually
okay i'm going to go b5 and if he goes
bishop h3 i'm probably going to leave
the rook on e6 or queen e8
sac the exchange 200 bits thank you evan
oh and of course i blown it again
fortunately i have e4
and i'm still in the game somehow
despite the multitude of blunders i have
committed in this game
but again he's playing well on this
match this is manca s and america
another sub thank you
appreciate you guys support despite my
crappy play
and my play is crappy i don't want to
hear any uh false false
words of praise from you guys queen
takes e4 okay that surprises me slightly
okay what if i go here how does he
actually crack my position though
maybe this is a sacrifice i don't know
maybe this whole thing is planned
27 is strong
just too blundery another subcasparo
thank you thank you kasparov wannabe i
appreciate your support
throughout my streaming career keep them
coming guys love it
love it love it love it you guys
oh and i blended in the night like an
idiot i blended the night
unbelievable i mean this is just crazy
the amount of blunders thank you for 100
bits
this is ridiculous
i'm distracted too i need to focus
thanks uh ivy for the sub
i've never bloated like this so many
times it's ridiculous
yeah why am i even playing right now
yeah i just got
just got the bishop there i used to get
a bit of
compensation i want to focus
eric's not an e5 player let me crush him
here
thank you for the sub uh five bucks from
moncalli i appreciate it
yeah i'm angry at myself because of the
amount of of blunders even the last game
i came back at a decent position that
blundered my night
just gotta focus there's not enough not
not concentrated right now
could be playing so much better
oh yeah he's got this missing his ideas
again e3 maybe
still up a point though even playing as
i am
man that's a bad move again takes rook
c8
okay d5 whatever
okay decent position a4 maybe incoming
yeah he's allowing it which is good c4 i
missed but then b4
i've got a nice position here
c4 a4 and rook a5 and rk4
is a no-brainer
okay got him there
got him relatively tight up if i go g3
h4
okay now g4 at the right moment is like
a typical rye lopez idea
you basically distract him he wants
knight c5
yeah he does want knight c5 so let's
think
i can meet knight c5 with g4 that would
be an interesting thought
i can also go queen e2 for now let's see
what he does
okay now g4 is kind of tempting
yeah let's go g4 just over extending him
here at least i'm trying to
trying to play like the the rai lopez
masters would play
okay now normally the way that this is
played
you go g5 and then you establish a
stronghold
on f6 potentially so closing the
position up is questionable decision but
knight f5 check is very tempting you
know
very tempting night sacrifice
but i'm gonna go here for now let's see
what he does
stopping i assume knight c5 because of
this check
yeah now i need to employ
knight f5 is super tempting i mean
it's got to be good knight f5 has got to
be good that's just the way it's just
the way capoblanco would have played it
and he's also got less time so
sacrificing a night but
obviously i've got humongous
compensation here i would imagine
if i win this game it'll be very big
morale boost
showing me that i can still play some
chess occasionally
yeah but now i thought i'd take
okay seriously this works
what if i go here here and take
it's one option there there in h5 is
another
probably this is the best oh no but he
goes there
cried
okay therefore i have to take
queen g8 i'll go h5 this is either m and
i they're gonna crash and burn here it's
gonna be an amazing game
f7 is tempting
h5 obviously
yeah but now he cannot take on f6 again
so he's extended his problem here queen
g8 is forced
i would imagine but he's he's running
very short of time here
h6 is coming in yeah
everybody there's no way he's going to
make this is there
unless i blend her a fork which is i
will not put past him and put put it
past myself
mate threatened h6 that's a good
good game by him i was definitely
already playing too slowly
which makes the sacrifice that much
better
excellent that is what we call a chess
game
that was a great game because that's
like massive time shows me that i can
still play some goddamn chess
yeah so this time he doesn't blunder the
pun maybe that's for the best though
and i like these positions actually
allowing d4 though why would i do that
okay i'll take it and i'll probably
plant the no
just not crisp okay i guess d5 is
interesting
hg3 so we'll leave the knight there on
ip6
b8 preemptively definitely worse here
again out of the opening
h4
just going to thrash me here at this
rate
okay
queen c3 and he's just busting me open i
have some
basic ideas with rook c8 now queen b4
if i can trade queens here i'll be more
or less fine
yeah but that's why he goes queen b3 but
now he's
now the knights kind of planted on c4 my
queen is heading to b5 i think i'm
okay but let's not rush with that
definitely i feel like my only serious
source of counterplay is the queen side
so that's where i should probably
operate
okay let's go let's play this slow okay
but i'm not too scared of that move
i don't see how he's going to follow
this up oh he wants knight g foot that's
how he's going to follow it up
he's going to spread me wide here on the
queen side
the king side as charlie would say
i feel like i'm holding on by the hair
on my chinny chin chin here i mean it's
so close already
eric is just so strong okay but he
blunders this
this this this is a big time game
changer this move
i think i don't know knight f7 knight t1
knight t8
probably he's got to go knight f7 i
would imagine
knight d198 rook c1
takes sticks and that doesn't work i
have to take he takes
yeah he's got to go knight f7 here but
he misses it
instead this is good for me now and i've
got to push this home
this is a huge chance to take control of
this match
bishop h6 he's gonna go rookie one
but no no bishop
let's go queen h6 let's just park the
queen here i don't wanna
do anything we wild see one anyway
yeah i see what he wants that's a great
move
cried rick
you can draw me if i go there all right
fine i'll go here i'll play for a win
i want to win this goddamn game
now we need to bring the beef in all
right okay he can take my monolith for
all i care
oh no actually
now i thought f6 makes sense
now maybe f5
too slow
way too slow
how is he so fast all of a sudden the
speed coming from
wait should be five as much stronger
there
[ __ ] that up so hard
to draw are we counting draws you guys
you could say
there at the end but i'm wasting a lot
of very very uh level-headed game
i was also completely lost there at some
point did ross count orpheus
let's play the goldstein
i mean that was great quality of play at
the end
i was also a one point lost
i think 10 points so are we i guess
we're
we're we're counting draws which is i
guess good for me i'm up two points
okay we're going to take we're going to
play as a slow roll here
okay just let me know 10 wins probably
is in the chest press spirit
okay i'm going to try to just spread
them open on the king's side here
this is already good for me it should be
theory
first to 10. okay we need to decide the
policy here
i'm not playing this one well that's for
sure
okay obviously h5
uh do draws count for the ten points so
is it are we counting the draw or is it
still four to two is what i mean
are we counting that toward the the
counter to ten
is what i mean
whoa really really riley
what if i take and just double
okay so counting okay points yes counts
okay got it got it orpheus thank you
got it got it got it i just meant is it
draw a valid half point
does it bring me closer to ten okay so
then it's a great result
for me f6 i'm just intuitively going to
play rook h1
just go for his throat there
yeah i don't see a defense and this is
nerve-wracking
okay net f6 he's trying
it might be his only chance here
so let me think
okay c3c5 this gotta be winning for me
somehow
how can you just defend like this
knight back to e4 yeah but now i can
double
really so he allows this you know
be serious and he's telling me that
there's no mate here yeah
you want to tell me in good conscience
that there is no checkmate in this
freaking position
maybe i don't know but fg looks
mighty crushing to me
okay let's take here so i don't have to
think about the knight
maybe bishop d3 was somehow mating i
don't know
i feel like king g495 it's got to be
made i have so many pieces here on the
attack
okay see if i doesn't even try to
prevent it okay
okay bishop d3 king g495 king g3 rook h3
king g2 bishop before king f2 rook have
three king turk h2 king one knight t3
bishop before king g495 rock h3
uh if he goes king f2 there i have
knight g4 king g2 bishop e4 i think it's
mating
probably mistaken in my calculations but
okay
yeah knight g4 is what i calculated
king g one force and then bishop b4 is
made of king g tubish before rook f1
rook h2 mate
it's just me no stopping rock each one
look at this position
yeah no idea what was going on in that
opening
let's try this whoa 200 bits thank you
appreciate it man thanks for the hype
appreciate it keep it coming d5 okay
again i'm
probably slightly worse knight 65
there's one thing i can do in chess and
that's calculate
okay now i got some piece activity to
compensate for the
for the what for the bad structure i
guess
that was bad i think i'm constantly
struggling with black that's a problem
c5 bishop b5
maybe i have some knight c3 ideas
against rook c6
the other knight c3 was probably much
stronger
but i'm stupid
so stupid i should have gone to the
other night okay he can give up the
bishop for two
for two pieces but i shouldn't be worse
there i take on a2
should be enough counter play to make to
squeeze out a draw
you know just making things here bishop
c4 might be very unpleasant nighty too
okay goes for it i guess because he has
to
now i probably should push my pawn
so a5 he goes he wants king g2 i could
also try to go rogue b8
and he has already bishop c4
rookie seven maybe i think this is a key
key defensive move rookie seven stopping
rook c7
stopping stopping his rook penetration
okay he goes rook c6
but now i can start pushing i think
safely
we can keep pushing just push the spawn
up very far
knight g5 he doesn't really mind the
pawn
okay i'm fine with the draw here yeah so
he's bailing out i think
i'm an off-road draw
yeah okay good good result we're fine
with draws with black as long as i can
win with white
problem is yeah
the two pieces are good enough
to contain the rooks when i beat the
books
as long as i can win those white games
fine with the black draw now white is
not lost therapist i think it's a draw
even with best play i mean i don't i'm
not really okay maybe i wasn't as
ambitious as i should have been there
but
i'm confident of my chances with white
so not too concerned about that results
just need to keep building it building
the lead here while i have a big
advantage in momentum
okay b4 knight d5 is obviously my idea
after this match i'm gonna go you guys
because i still have to pack and stuff
okay knight t5 looks too tempting not to
be played
yeah eddie should be lost f6
so that's a good move knight c7 king yes
that's such an eric hanson move
okay i have to do this daniel style
probably on sound but i feel like it
affords a lot of practical chances
have to try this daniel style
it is a very like handsome move okay
he's gonna like get the better of me
here isn't he
he's gonna catch me on overzealous play
yeah this pawn i forgot is hanging there
to take
okay here i have to find something
what did i do why did i sack this
stupid and now i'm kind of lost
i mean i just gifted him this one or did
i i don't know
should be two i guess see i i for even
forgot queen c7 doesn't work
unbelievable thank you joshua yala day
for the win
for the sub
okay now i have to pull one off and i
have to pull a fast one on him
if i can win this one that really makes
a big dent
it's another one in the can
okay i have some ideas here i have um a
pawn for the piece and i
and he's he has a formidable defensive
task ahead of him with not a lot of time
so
it's not all bad bishop g7 no
queen of four rook t1
but he's so accurate in defending these
positions
it's crazy hey cappy
and i blundered right into this ah but
then queen c3 fortunately
trying to catch him on some sort of slip
i'm i'm i mean this is just disgraceful
this is so poor
very bad i didn't i shouldn't have
sacrificed now i'm down a piece
i mean it's he's got some mopping up to
do here but
maybe he gets nervous i don't know
we'd see two is his intention
he wants queen c2 and there's very
little i can do to stop him
no no no no oh my god oh damn it's
it's about primo but i'm still easily
winning i guess for him
okay let's go
he's going for this again
now i'm going to win i'm tired of
dilly-dallying around
just just gotta crush him stop i i just
got to stop this stupid sacrifices and
just win positionally
tired of these these stupid unthought of
sacrifices are costing me games
i feel like positionally i cannot play
him
i mean eric is a very strong positional
player as well but
he's he's super good at defending
against unsound sacrifice i think that's
one of his strengths so
i gotta be super solid
what am i doing keep the lead up three
or four
not a good opening eric all right let's
move back
let's tuck our tail in between our legs
this knight is awkward maybe six
okay deform interesting move
leading to complications
so ed you want snipe okay probably i
should take knight takes
and maybe queen ticks i don't know i
don't know what to make of this
probably i'm worse yeah probably just
much worse
this should be fun that surprises me
though thought he'd play knight takes
okay now i have this though okay now i
can
now i have an edge because because my
rooks i mean my pieces are very active
here this is my type of position
rook takes c1 rook takes c1e he's
banking on his b-pawn that makes sense
actually
his b-pawn is running very fast
so he's trying to trick me i see
he's he wants me to take on c1 but i
think i have this
at least
oh no no no that was bad oh my god
i forgot his rook on a once defended
it just takes and returns to e1 and i'm
much worse what am i doing
just anything else and i'm and i'm
totally fine anything else and i'm
totally fine
knight d7 rook v8
no i have to blunder
bleach complete choke is what i am
play choke
still i have some chances here but not
many
amazingly everything is somehow
miraculously protected
but as of by miracle
i want bishop a6 and win
i thought i have some d3 related counter
play
but he's got knight d2 damn it's
oh but i have rookie two maybe bishop g3
unbelievable this is unbelievable
okay bishop a seven then
there's gonna be another close one i can
sense it okay i can
win the pawn back at least so i have
some defensive chances
maybe i can salvage a draw
should be four ones
i have to work hard that game with the
50s some of the worst chess i've ever
played actually
two pieces versus a rook it's always
that was a bit of a challenge
to coordinate i don't know what the
theory is
can i play this move
it's probably probably a blender or
something eh
[ __ ] okay yeah i don't know theory here
sorry guys
oh my god i want it again
should i meet out some bands or are we
gonna watch and behave
normally
all right
all right when i thrash him 10 is five
we'll we'll see who's still talking
thanks grant
no it's not 300 it's a hundred i mean
300 on the line would be nice but i
appreciate every i appreciate
orpheus's
kindness in making this match possible
i wondered there actually he had an
interesting idea
maybe queen d2 was better
you want 25.
let's try this one
i don't know what to make of this my
king is in a lot of danger
i'm gonna have six plundered again
rocket and he's probably winning
let's try this maybe to save my king
there
okay five c3 makes sense i gotta keep a
time advantage i mean he's so fast that
he's much faster than me and finding
good moves then maybe send that seep on
down the line
maybe this one just to soften them up a
little bit
and then go back
to four 97 maybe
is this a move
could be winning potentially
or not
this being a huge threat
i just hung up on what happened here
next game what happened here
thanks john
i don't trust i mean he keeps going to
the c3 but why is this
so good for him i don't get it is this
supposed to be that good for him
let's try this again
i'm going to take with the knight this
time
okay queen b3 i guess knight bd7 makes a
lot of sense
now this is a nice position and there's
just no way
that this is that good for him
he wants b4 i need to stop it
b3 i have some night g4 ideas for
example
queen h4 okay knight f3 and eric is
annoying
okay
oh god this one disappeared
man this obs update is ridiculous
let's try to spice things up a little
bit tabasco sauce
thank you artichoke for the sub
appreciate it guys appreciate the
support
every sub is good don't get me wrong i
appreciate each and every sub
in each and every bit i don't expect
anything
from anyone
rookie five was interesting yeah rookie
five was probably much stronger
now he gets his pieces out
h5 was a good option there
i want to pave the way for the knight to
come to d4 potentially
if bishop b2 i can just go back to d4
probably
okay goes with the queen
probably just go back honestly if you
want to draw you can get it
yes though i could play this position
for a win i guess
but i don't really see the needs okay he
does
okay queen c6 i saw kind of intuitively
didn't think it was that good though
i guess i thought wrong
unreal
rook g1 is a threat so he's got a take
and then i take i mean it's
it's defensible i guess it's gonna burn
some clock here calculating variations
basically with eric okay misses it isn't
this mate though
it's maiden so he just wanted mate
you've under made it to you guys
lucky as usual okay that was a huge win
and i need to win another one and then
another one and then we're good
check and checkmate
anybody talking now
okay if it ain't broke don't fix it c5
let's go c3 sicilian let's go with this
residentialist variation
it's it's reputable it's good it's solid
okay i think you're supposed to do this
okay so he wants rook t8 i need to deal
with that
okay i guess no need to be draw suits me
so
i need to be crazy here
and thank you stokesy for the subway
twitch prime appreciate it
thank you you guys for all the subs
now i have this move maybe and then
bishop e3
um
yeah i knew you would do this
now i have a couple of options
maybe this one i just played bishop c5
i guess he missed it but he is
fortunately for him bishop b7
okay now i take though
now i need a good move queen b4 queen b5
and queen b4
now we probably start collecting
and
here now we need another good move
probably just bring this guy in
defensive purposes a5 i missed but
okay
just extending the pressure here a
little bit oh and i blundered didn't i
that was a horrendous move fortunately
okay if i want to have a bailout
i probably should take it i have a bail
on here
yeah okay i'm still up a pawn which is
the good news the bad news is i'm low on
time
this [ __ ] thanks what if i just take
though
i don't get it i guess we'll find out
bishop h3 i have even bishop g2 should
be winning for me
i'm careful ship g4
okay i'll still go bishop g2 two pawns
up here i mean
it's gotta be winning rook d2
okay first of all let's go h3 when i
blundered this
ugh that is a nasty little move
and i forgot he has queen queen f8
that's what actually that's what i
missed
okay let's go here and then try to
confuse him a little bit
so i can check him oh my goodness what
am i doing
what if i go here though oh queen v6 of
course conveniently has a defense
rook d2 what am i doing
maybe rook details just bail out quincy
one let's go for the draw
okay i'm still better here for sure have
some chances to win perhaps
especially if i can speed up my ass look
at
us
you can't take
okay i thought i couldn't take it i
guess you can
that's made i win it's mate
okay let's get this let's get this show
in the room
wondering when it was a good d4 probably
that's a shame no he sticks with it okay
well i got a nice position the last time
i guess
so if it ain't broke don't fix it
okay d4 immediately interesting i guess
you want c5
yeah that's annoying
okay let's keep going just gotta
can't let this guy get let this sit this
lead sit and then you know you start to
doubt yourself just gotta knock him out
while i'm ahead
except i'm worse significantly worse
let's try queen b6 here okay but i
thought i could
take here i'm just gonna go for it here
if i if i lose a game i lose a game but
not i'm not going to play defensively
just to
[ __ ] around here
definitely much worse but we'll see what
i can do here
okay where does the
queen go oh then he wants rook b1 the
rascal
wow that is annoying
that is very annoying i have to go here
now he moves this rook again
yeah he's definitely not going down
without a fight that's for sure
i'm kind of paralyzed
okay let's tempt him into an end game
maybe maybe i can save this
not even looking to win but draw maybe
maybe i can salvage a draw and then
that'll really put it put it on him
okay knight p3 he's very confident in
his end game play
yeah but he's just winning here
it was a shitty game
really had no chances there
from the beginning
okay maybe let's not okay that was a
mistake by him a4 allowed a4
or no that was a mistake by me maybe
before it was shitty
i wanted to go e5 i don't know what my
follow-up's gonna be maybe knight b6
maybe that a3984
now if he takes i win this might be a
crusher you guys
because if he doesn't move then i fork
him simply i'm up a piece here
yeah this should be winning
that's not he's gonna find something
he does have e6 here but that doesn't
really work
yeah i don't see him i he has no defense
simply
yeah this is over this is just over
unless my internet fails he's got no
time either
the worst comes to worst i flag him got
him
who's talking now huh all right gg is
daniel what did i tell you when it was
five
six what did i say when it was five six
all right good games eric lucky there
many times as usual
i think three or four garrick probably
the better player honestly orpheus whoa
holy smokes a ten thousand bum
enjoy us thank you orpheus you are the
man
10 000 big ones from orpheus
appreciate it man appreciate it um
holy smokes
yeah that was a nice nice final stretch
there i mean
i i really felt like the match was was
hanging
um in the in the air and then i managed
to sort of
get it together with that h4 night off
game thank you for the hundred bucks
orpheus
let's get this hype going i appreciate
it
thank you to eric of course you guys all
know who just brought chess bra
is but they are fantastic they are the
og streamers so give them your love in
case
you know in case there's anybody here
who doesn't know who they are they are
awesome eric and amman
they are a big reason i got into twitch
so worship thank you for the sub
[Music]
you